♪ ♪
>> Greg: SOMEWHERE IN THE
PARALLEL UNIVERSE, A HUGE NEW
STORY GOING ON ABOUT A TERROR
ATTACK IN FLORIDA AND NAVAL BASE
WHERE A SAUDI NATIONAL KILLED
THREE SAILORS.
EXPRESS EXTREMIST THOUGHTS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS THE NIGHT
BEFORE HE AND HIS PALS ALLEGEDLY
WATCHED MASS SHOOTING VIDEOS AND
TWO OF THE OTHER SAUDIS
THIS SHOULD RAISE KEY
CONTENTIONS IN THE MEDIA
APPEARED WHY ARE WE TRAINING SO
MANY SAUDIS?
HOW WE RESOLVED THAT A MAJORITY
OF THE 9/11 ATTACKERS WERE SAUDI
NATIONALS?
WHERE WAS ARMED SECURITY IN THIS
ATTACK?
THIS WOULD MATTER IN A PARALLEL
UNIVERSE BUT NOT THIS ONE
BECAUSE WE ARE TOO BUSY FILLING
SPACE WITH A SHAM IMPEACHMENT.
A DOUBLE WHAMMY OF DESTRUCTION.
NOT ONLY IS THERE A FALSE
IMPEACHMENT TO EXHAUST YOUR
BRAIN BUT REPLACES INFORMATION
YOU NEED TO KNOW.
YOU KNOW LESS ABOUT YOUR REALITY
WHILE CARING MORE ABOUT MEDIA
GENERATED GARBAGE IN YOUR BRAIN.
WE KNOW HOW FAKE THE IMPEACHMENT
CIRCUS WAS PREDICATED ON A
COMICALLY FAKE DOSSIER BUT ALL
STORIES NEED TO BE BASED ON HOW
EVIL TRUMP IS.
IF WE BLAME THEM SHOOTING ON
TRUMP -- YOU SEE THE WORD PAY?
ATTENTION AS CURRENCY.
WHEN YOU PAY IT'S ONE THING, YOU
DON'T PAY IT TO ANOTHER AND YOU
ONLY HAVE SO MUCH FOR THE MEDIA
EVERY DAY TO ROB YOU BLIND.
SO, KATIE, THIS HAPPENED IN A
GUN FREE ZONE.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE SECOND FACT
YOU LEARN.
>> THE GUN FREE ZONE IS CLEARLY
NOT A GUN FREE ZONE.
GUN DON'T MAKE BAD GUYS BRING
GUNS AND GUN FREE ZONES AND THEY
TERRORIZE PEOPLE WHO KILL PEOPLE
UNARMED.
THE FORT HOOD SHOOTING IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF SOLDIERS
SAYING WE ARE TRAINED PEOPLE.
OUT OF ALL THE PEOPLE IN AMERICA
WHO SHOULD BE ABLE TO CARRY
FIREARMS, WE ARE THEM.
THEY CONTINUALLY REFUSED THAT
ABILITY AND THE RIGHT.
THE OTHER THING ABOUT THIS THAT
I FIND EXTREMELY INTERESTING AND
ALSO ENRAGING -- IF WE HAVE A
TRAVEL BAN ON PEOPLE COMING TO
AMERICA FROM COUNTRIES THAT
SUPPORT TERRORISM AND WE CAN VET
THEM PROPERLY, WE SHOULD
CERTAINLY NOT ALLOW THEM TO BE
PURCHASING FIREARMS IN AMERICA.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT, AS A
FLORIDA GOVERNOR SAID, IS
RESERVED FOR AMERICAN CITIZENS.
IT'S AN AMERICAN RIGHT.
IF YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM LEGALLY, YOU
SHOULDN'T
HAVE DONE LIKE YOU SHOULD HAVE
TO BECOME AN AMERICAN AND BE
PART OF OUR SOCIETY AND EMBRACEW
PART OF OUR SOCIETY AND EMBRACEE
BELIEVE IN.
THE IDEA THEY HAVE THIS LOOPHOLE
IS PRETTY RIDICULOUS AND
SOMETHING CONGRESS TO CHANGE.
SPEED TO THAT LOOPHOLE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, HE GOT A HUNTING
LICENSE AND THEN HE GETS THE
GUN.
BUT IT'S NOT A HUNTING GUN.
>> Katie: THAT'S IRRELEVANT,
THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE FOR
NATIONAL SPECIFICALLY FROM
COUNTRIES WHERE THERE IS A LONG
HISTORY OF TERRORISM COMING FROM
AMERICA TO PURCHASE FIREARMS FOR
WHATEVER PURPOSE.
>> Juan: I AGREE WITH YOU.
I'M SURPRISED YOU CAN BE A
FOREIGN NATIONAL AND JUST GO GET
A GUN.
>> Katie: CAN I SAY ONE MORE
THING ABOUT THE GUN FREE ZONE
ISSUE?
THEY ALWAYS DISARM PEOPLE ON GUN
FREE ZONE ISSUES WHETHER
MILITARY
95% OF THE TIME THEY DON'T
PROVIDE SECURITY.
THEY TELL YOU YOU CAN'T PROTECT
YOURSELF BUT THEY DON'T PROVIDE
YOU THE ACCURATE RESOURCES TO
PROTECT YOU AND I WONDER WHAT
WILL BE THE LEGAL LIABILITY OF
THAT.
TAKING AWAY SOMEBODY'S ABILITY
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES, PUT THEM
IN A VULNERABLE SITUATION.
SOMETHING HAPPENS AND EVERYONE
WALKS AWAY TO COME UP WITH ALL
THE SOLUTIONS IN THE AFTERMATH.
I THINK THAT'S A VERY SERIOUS
QUESTION THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT.
>> Greg: JUAN, DO YOU THINK
TRUMP IS TOO SOFT ON THE SAUDIS
ON THIS?
>> Juan: I DO.
HE HAD A CONVERSATION WITH THE
PRINCE, THE PRINCE TOLD HIM NOT
TO WORRY.
I WAS, LIKE, WHAT?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I WAS SURPRISED.
KATIE AND I AGREE PIT I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN HAVE SOME BUDDY
COME INTO THE COUNTRY AS A
FOREIGN NATIONAL AND SUDDENLY BE
ALLOWED TO PURCHASE A FIREARM
WITHOUT SOME -- I IMAGINE SOME
VERY GOOD REASON THE MILITARY
WOULD PROVIDE BUT NOT IN
GENERAL.
SECONDLY, GIVEN THE MURDER OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" COLUMNIST
WHICH THE PRESIDENT DID NOT
RESPOND AGGRESSIVELY, AND NOW
THIS, I DON'T UNDERSTAND -- I
JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T SAY, WHICH IS
WHAT GREG SAID IN HIS MONOLOGUE,
I CAN DRAW A LINE FROM 9/11 TO
THIS EVENT AND SAY, BOY, LOTS
GOING ON HERE WITH THE SAUDIS
AND ANTI-AMERICAN SENTIMENT, WHY
WOULD I BE TRAINING SAUDIS WITH
AMERICAN MILITARY EQUIPMENT?
>> Jesse: THE REASON YOU DO
THAT BECAUSE WE CLEARED AN
8 BILLION MILITARY AID PACKAGE.
WE GIVE THEM THE C-130S, F-15S,
BOEING, LOCKHEED, WE NEED
TRAINED PILOTS TO FLY THESE VERY
EXPENSIVE TOYS.
WE CAN'T SEND IT IT'S THERE TO
FLY THESE PLANES.
WE NEED GUYS TRAINED UP, WILL WE
ARE THE BEST PEOPLE TO TRAIN
THEM, WE NEED TO FIGHT A
REIGNING AGGRESSION THERE,
THAT'S THE REASON WE DO IT.
BUT THEY DESTROYED OUR TRUST.
YOU ARE GOING TO COME IN HERE,
BECAUSE IN OUR HOME, AND JUST
SHOOT PEOPLE?
NO.
LIKE YOU SAID, THESE HIJACKERS
ON 9/11 WERE SAUDI.
SUNNIS ARE PREDOMINANTLY ISIS
PEOPLE.
THERE IS A REAL PROBLEM THERE.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHY THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T SAY SOMETHING A LOT
STRONGER ON THIS.
HE SHOULD.
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY A PROBLEM WE
ARE DEALING WITH.
WE HAVE TO SHUT THIS DOWN.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE BUYING GUNS.
I THINK SAUDI ARABIA THIS WEEK,
I THINK IT WAS THE BIGGEST IPO
OF ALL TIME.
THE OIL COMPANY NOW $2 TRILLION
EVALUATION, BIGGER THAN APPLE.
WE AREN'T ROCKING THE BOAT,
EVERYBODY'S GETTING RICH.
BUT THERE IS NO EXCUSE.
>> Dana: SOME ARE WITHOUT
THEIR FAMILIES, LOVED ONES THIS
HOLIDAY.
>> Greg: WITH A RAN
IRAN, LEADERSHIPBAD, PEOPLE GOOD
IRAN, LEADERSHIPBAD, PEOPLE GOO.
WE GET ALONG WITH THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE PEOPLE ARE MORE EXTREME.
>> Dana: IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
ELIMINATE ALL RISKS.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THIS SENTENCE,
SAUDI AVIATION STUDENT IN
FLORIDA?
WHERE HAVE I HEARD THIS BEFORE?
BESIDES, THE PRESIDENT IS
SENDING A BUNCH OF TRIPS TO
SAUDI ARABIA.